what's up everyone it's Warren and this
week for superhero fans is going to be
absolutely incredible yesterday we got
the official Black Widow teaser trailer
and not to mention this week we're
supposed to get another birds-of-prey
trailer and this weekend we're supposed
to get the Wonder Woman 1984 teaser
trailer as well and not to mention this
weekend is the Comic Con experience at
Sao Paulo Brazil otherwise known as CC
XP and it has been confirmed that Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
will be in attendance and will have a 45
minute panel so we can expect some
footage from phase 4 and most likely
some phase 5 announcements as well and
we just received some very exciting news
and that is that Ryan Reynolds is going
to be in attendance at CC XP as well
he's going to be there to promote some
of the other films that he's in not in
the MCU but Marvel does have a tendency
to take actors who were there for other
reasons and bring them onto their panel
and when they do this they usually have
some pretty big announcements for
example in 2016 at San Diego Comic Con
brie Larson was there to promote Kong
Skull Island but later on at San Diego
comic-con during Marvel Studios as panel
she was announced as Captain Marvel for
the very first time and last year at cc
XP was when Jake Gyllenhaal was
announced as Mysterio now Jake
Gyllenhaal announced that he was
Mysterio a few days before CC XP but at
CC XP was the first time when Marvel
Studios announced it so it could be very
likely that we're going to get a
Deadpool 3 announcement this weekend
coming up at cc XP now it's not
confirmed but let's take a look at
Marvel Studios as panel they have 45
minutes and it's Kevin Feige that's
going to be hosting the panel 45 minutes
is quite a lot of time to talk about
phase 4 even if they do show us some
clips that's still a lot of time so we
know that they're going to be talking
about phase 5 and Marvel has already set
some dates for phase 5 and at San Diego
comic-con Kevin Feige has admitted that
they know everything that's going to be
happening in phase 5 already basically
saying they have the lineup and of
course now that they have the Fox
properties like Deadpool the Fantastic
Four the x-men it's time to move them
over and what's the easiest one to move
over well of course it's Deadpool
because it's already established Ryan
Reynolds is going to continue to be
playing Deadpool this has already been
confirmed whereas for the Fantastic Four
and the x-men
have to recast and do original stories
so really it's not that hard for
Deadpool to enter the MCU in Phase five
and Ryan Reynolds has kind of been
hinting at it lately as most of you I'm
sure recall Ryan Reynolds posted on
Instagram a picture of him at Marvel
Studios well what do you think he was at
Marvel Studios for who do you think he
was meeting with and for what reason of
course it's about Deadpool 3 so Ryan
Reynolds has met with Marvel Studios
recently and it has been confirmed by cc
XP that he is going to be in attendance
this weekend so it seems like we could
be getting an official announcement for
Deadpool 3 this weekend we know they're
going to be talking about phase 5 in the
future of the MCU so hopefully Deadpool
is a part of that how excited would you
be if they announced Deadpool 3 this
weekend let me know in the comments down
below and of course don't forget to
subscribe turn notifications on and like
this video so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
winner gets to choose you can also click
the link it down below to enter for a
chance to win an Infinity Gauntlet and
as always thank you all so much for
watching will fluff